in completely inappropriate news today
we learned that first lady Melania Trump
ordered the firing of a national
security staffer and that that person
has indeed been fired Mira Ricard el has
been the deputy national security
advisor to the president working below
national security adviser John Bolton
since May of this year May of 2018 and
recently the first lady and Ricard el
went to Africa and it turns out that
Ricard el was not getting along with
Melania Trump's staff one report says
that the disagreements included where
people were going to sit on the flight
to Africa not exactly serious
life-altering stuff but they weren't
getting along
Ricardo also previously was having some
conflicts with defense secretary Jim
mattis there have been reports of
tension between Ricard el and
potentially soon to be fired chief of
staff John Kelly that's another story
but the chaos in the White House and
then yesterday reportedly catching the
White House off guard Melania Trump
Sophos put out a statement saying that
quote it is the position of the office
of the first lady that Ricardo no longer
deserves the honor of serving in this
White House and hours after that we
learned that indeed Mira Ricard el has
been fired by Donald Trump the first
lady publicly slammed a national
security staffer and reports are that
neither Trump nor chief of staff John
Kelly nor press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders knew that the statement was
going to be put out they were caught off
guard and indeed that staffer has now
been fired the first lady's office is
making decisions about who handles
national security in the United States
of America if you are national security
adviser John Bolton Pat and one of your
staffers has been fired because the
first lady didn't like her what do you
do now
what is John Bolton going to do about
the fact that the first lady is making
staffing decisions for him this is a new
level of ridiculousness and absurdity
isn't it
no I don't know because I think if you
look at American history first ladies
have had different levels of influence
Hillary Clinton for example was in
charge of pioneering and championing
universal health care and the violence
against women at woman's act and I know
the Bellagio boys has played a secondary
role like she's playing you know
backseat position here in the White
House she hasn't been that vocal and
active in forming policy but if she
wants to get a particular staffer fired
particularly one who hasn't been Senate
confirmed I think it's fair game that's
my take on it this is not Melania being
best as she likes to say and just
consider for a second okay so Hillary
tried to do health care in the 90s fine
if it had leaked that Michelle Obama
privately influenced the firing of even
a speechwriter to Barack Obama Fox News
and Rush Limbaugh would have been
covering it wall-to-wall every single
day for months this was a public
statement about a national security
staffer the second-in-command to John
Bolton by the first lady this is
actually an important job related to
national security and we're barely
hearing a word about it from the
right-wing media that they are pathetic
hypocrites and you can say Pat that
Hillary Clinton was involved in trying
to do health care okay that's one thing
but Hillary Clinton was not at least in
this way
deciding through public statements who
gets fired by the President of the
United States if your argument is well
listen David this stuff is going on
behind the scenes either way this is
just the the White House the the first
lady's office rather making a public
statement about it it doesn't change the
fact that this is actually happening
behind the scenes all the time okay well
we can look at that argument and then we
can debate it on its merits but the idea
that Melania Trump knows anything about
who should be in a position of ensuring
the national security of the United
States is unquestionably unfounded I
mean we can't defend that can we Pat but
do you see any difference between a
national security staffer someone who is
not Senate confirmed and say someone who
is in a
cabinet position like a Secretary of
State like can you can you make a
difference between the two of those
things there is a difference but either
way Melania Trump is not qualified to
decide who is the number two national
security person in the United States yes
she's not saying fire the Secretary of
State that would be different but this
is still plenty bad I feel like there
are maybe a thousand things that we can
criticize going on in the Trump
administration right now and for me this
just doesn't rank that highly on the
list in regards to that right wing media
point that you made I think that they're
just way too busy covering the caravan
covering the midterm election recounts
there there's a lot of stuff going on
right now it's a fear monger about well
we've now got a thousand and one things
on that list and this is certainly one
of them I got one email which said hey
David there's no way that Melania did
this without approval this is clearly a
plot to distract from something else
maybe upcoming indictments from Muller
well it did leak that supposedly molar
indictments are coming soon but this is
a little too well orchestrated for it to
be a calculated distraction I don't even
give them that much credit send me your
thoughts are you more on the pat side of
the Melania dictating who is in charge
of national security of the United
States or are you more on my side of
this or is there some other position we
haven't considered the show is on
Twitter a David Pakman show I am on
Twitter at D Pakman follow us and let me
know your thoughts today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman blinka is a great service
that I use all the time what they do is
they take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink as' I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book
jobs by David Graeber which I listen to
on bling cos they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink is calm slash Pakman
if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/p a que mas